l'équipe de montigny ensemble présenter
aux habitants les 39 nom comporte autant
d'anciens de la majorité municipale
venus apporter leur expérience que de
nouveaux pour un regard neuf dans cette
équipe j'ai fait rentrer des gens qui
étaient tous des personnes investies
soit dans le milieu associatif soit dans
les conseils de quartier
les rôles sont distribués en fonction
des appétences et compétences de chacun
je vais déjà essayer d'être au plus près
des des parents d'élèves et également
des enseignants déjà dans un premier
temps de faire un tour d'horizon des
questions qui peuvent se poser des
problèmes qui se posent pour essayer de
bien diagnostiqué le sujet et
naturellement aussi les jo qui va être
une grande fête et qu'il faut qu'on
réussisse au mieux laurens merkel a
aussi présenté certaines propositions de
son programme réhabilitation du
centre-ville sécurité le contact avec
les habitants et une fiscalité mesurer
et maîtriser seront les points
importants avec aussi l'environnement
pour lequel il propose la création d'une
délégation mêlant fiscalité et
transition écologique
je pense qu'aujourd'hui si on veut pas
être dans le discours mais dans la mise
en oeuvre de d'un vrai projet de
transition écologique
le nerf de la guerre c'est l'argent et
donc si on veut avoir une vraie
transformation des services de la ville
il faut situer la transition écologique
au niveau de la gestion des finances
puisque c'est la finance qui arbitre
tout ce qui va se jouer dans les autres
services
l'équipe montini ensemble va désormais
présenter son programme complet aux
habitants chaque week end et poursuivre
les réunions d'appartement déjà engagé
deux autres listes sont engagés dans la
commune